all right so normally Spencer I would
say welcome to New York but for you it's
welcome back to New York yeah have you
officially settled in fully back in New
York and with the team of course
uh Saturday and back to New York not at
all I'm still in a hotel
um living the life of a guy that got
traded a couple weeks ago but in terms
of the team you're doing a great job
welcoming me and a lot of the you know
front office do the same so it's right
back to business
so what was the process though of easy
back into the team was it easier than
you thought harder than you thought
about the same oh
um
I don't know if I had any explicit
thoughts I think um I got traded Dallas
was already kind of an established like
culture hierarchy all that other stuff
um with the way the trade deadline went
down with the Nets you knew that it was
just gonna all be new so I don't think I
really had expectations to just kind of
like let's see where this goes yeah
tell me three ways that you are a
different player now than you were the
first time around
oh
um
I think I'm stronger
um obviously every time you go through
the rehab process you learn little
Nuance about your body so last time Nets
fan saw me I was hurt I think um
basketball iq's gotten higher just uh be
able to experience different
organizations different uh philosophies
um and although it doesn't show right
now in the last like 10 games I've been
a better three-point shooter I
am showing at the moment
uh just changing scenery uh types of
looks
um you know when I was in Dallas I shot
a lot of catch shoot threes a lot of
corner threes too
um right now I've unfortunately had to
take a lot of grenades and like late
clock bombs and stuff like that which
obviously uh typically isn't good for
your percentage Yeah but I'm
understand you gotta
risk for that exact reason well exactly
I mean I would say if I probably took
out the late Hues I'd probably be
shooting mid 30s right now to be honest
but
um it's about winning the game if I can
give ourselves a chance a little bit
better chance I'm gonna do it great okay
so with Bridges right now yeah tell me
what you thought about him before he was
your teammate and what you think of him
now that he's your teammate
um
pre-teammate Elite Defender
um seemed like a High character guy he
always ran a little curl play with
Phoenix
um you know you could catch and shoot I
actually talked a little uh
too
yeah I'm saying we actually uh had a
couple back and forth before uh when we
played Phoenix but did you like him like
was it all just friendly [__] talking it
was friendly so I was I was actually uh
busting ass one time and uh
he uh because we were getting the switch
because obviously he was a primary
Defender and he came to me and was like
oh man you you know you can't score on
me why you keep calling for the switch I
was like bro I'm oh shout out to reverse
psychology [__] I don't play that you
know I mean so it was fun it was just a
like back and forth
um but now I mean we're seeing him
develop into a Premiere probably number
one number two option as a as a scorer
um his ability to get to the mid-range
to knock down shots is his Elite
obviously there was so much news
surrounding the trade uh that led to you
being with the Nets a lot of moving
Parts definitely when you step back look
on it now do you feel like it's a trade
that worked out for all parties
um I think it's something that the tale
of the trade won't be told this season
you know I think if you look at it from
Dallas aside they got star power right
they got a another really high octane uh
player to to pair with Luca
um and you know hopefully it works out
for them if he doesn't resign though and
does go to the Lakers for example which
everybody always talks about then it's
probably not the best move for them
um for the Nets I think you know with
the moves that they made they uh kind of
got to restructure their roster
um more in line with probably who the
front office in you know ownership group
kind of wanted to have which I think has
been well documented
um and they also got a plethora of picks
which you know if they want to stay and
win now mode they've got a lot of guys
that are in that kind of uh age range
and caliber and then you take the pitch
you go try to find the guy and you know
you go from there
so for someone who's been to a few
different spots yeah do you ever get
used to being traded
no no I don't I I don't think so I mean
for the most part I've pretty much been
traded twice you know uh obviously uh
Dallas and then
um back to Brooklyn I mean technically
speaking four times because DC was a
signing trade and stuff like that but
not so much
um
it's just situations where a max player
wanted to go and I was in that tier two
where like hey he's a good talent his
contract plus another contract makes
sense and
you know that that's how it works it was
really interesting for me just obviously
prepping for this learning more about
your journey because it really has been
interesting and there's been a number of
ups and downs and certain things that
you've had to deal with in the NBA
how important is it to feel wanted in
this league
uh opportunity situation or everything
you know I think there's there's a
reason why a lot of the top picks are
you know Max guys and things of that
nature and the reason why a lot of
second round guys end up in China or
whatever what have you opportunities
everything and so to your point that
feeling wanted in somebody uh believing
in you and giving you a chance to make
mistakes
um is how your your career can flourish
I mean if if Kenny and Kenny and Sean
marks don't give me an opportunity what
is that now seven years ago
oh leg Asian dog years but uh then I
mean I'm not sitting here today yeah
do you remember the first time you felt
unwanted in the league
shoot like week two in Detroit
yeah uh
you know he just he was he was committed
to playing vets and I was a guy that's
like Steve Blake Steve Blake yeah yeah
John Lucas Steve Blake guys like that um
which you know having been in the league
now a long time you understand like on
the margins maybe they gave you you know
an extra charge taken or extra heady
play but obviously I'm biased I think
I'm more talented than they are
um I don't think many people probably
disagree with that but you know as a
young guy 20 years old coming off ACL
and you know he he was the guy that
wanted to make the the playoffs and you
know do it was right for his job
so coach would that have been Gundy yeah
have you ever been able to have
conversations later with Stan Van Gundy
about the player that you became yeah
yeah actually uh one of my last games in
Dallas he was doing a broadcast and he
we sat down for probably about 10
minutes he asked like what he could have
done differently and you know it's his
job as a coach to cultivate talent and
not you know
have it kind of go left the way that it
did so you know I I really appreciate
that man it's it's water under the
bridge for sure and honestly I've given
them as Kudos before in terms of shaping
my work ethic in terms of how to
approach being a true Pro in the league
um you know being two hours early to
practice and staying hour two hours
after and just be indulgent about your
habits and your work wait I love that so
because I don't think that a lot of
players and coaches are able to have
that moment of kind of reflection and
discourse about how things went or how
things didn't go so how did you all sit
down to talk you're doing the broadcast
did you come up to him he come to you no
he actually pulled me aside so I did my
pre-game shooting and you know he was at
his booth and uh he pulled me to the
side which I got a couple questions for
you I was like all right like what you
got you know I'm saying and yeah and we
sat down chopped it for about 10 minutes
and you know that was
it was it was a really actually cool
moment for me even though it was
something that I had probably let go a
couple years ago or several years ago
but it's almost a closure moment yeah
I'm saying uh and and a moment of
validation too
because it feels like so I read a quote
um you were talking to a reporter from
CBS and you said people don't understand
the mentality of a player who has been
told he wasn't good enough at every step
of his basketball life yeah that's how
you feel your journey has gone oh I was
done yeah every every single point in
time I mean oh sorry about hitting the
mic but uh I mean even now right like
you get traded for a Max guy you get
thrown into a a unique situation I know
a lot of Nets fans have Championship
expectations still for a group that's
only been together a month
um you know y'all lighten up my Twitter
mentions and all that stuff after every
loss at the same time on the bright side
you know if you extrapolate out my 15
games over the course of a season I'd be
top like three and assist you know what
I mean so there's there's always
positives to take from it and you when
you've always been in that Underdog or
uh not as badly Hood position you gotta
take the positives out the situation
so even now you still have these moments
of feeling like people don't think
you're good enough for sure yeah for
sure every every year all the time like
it's part of it I mean with the
entertainment industry at the end of the
day and there's a certain sex appeal to
a certain guys names and that's not uh
the life I live
so when you have these moments
where do you get the reassurance from
the facts of the situation
you know I mean there was I had a run
like three years in a row where I was
like a top five ISO guy I mean even last
year I was as well
um you know my time in Dallas was like
number one in points for possession
isolations and then you know like I said
if you extrapolate my Brooklyn time
already I'd be top three and assists in
the league like it just things like that
and so you know you can say what you
want but numbers don't lie so yes I have
Improvement to make in terms of uh
three-point shooting in this time period
but that's a positive I take from it so
just to further Define like this feeling
and this emotion that you're describing
right
what kind of player do you feel like
people think you are and what kind of
player do you think you think you are
and you know what's that difference
between the two oh uh
Mass are we talking about Mass Appeal
are we talking about coaches and front
offices are we talking about just
personally or all three I
would say a mix of all of it because if
if what you're referring to is a feeling
of not feeling like you're good enough
I'm sure that is coming from a variety
of like sources yeah so if we kind of
had a medley of those and averaged it
out what do you think people think and
what do you think okay okay
um
I think people think
I'm a dude that's crazy like in my mind
I think I'm uh number one or them
just not on I think I'm another one in
my mind but I'm not on that level or
whatever it is like it's it's usually
this like really split opinion type of
situation
um
which and I'm talking about more like
mass media and stuff then uh front
officers have gotten to know me I think
Dallas and Brooklyn obviously spend a
lot of time today kind of know uh who I
am and also how I view myself I think
you know
depend upon the type of Superstar I'm
playing with either second or third
option on a championship type team
um I mean Drew holiday in that sense
would be something that people would
like probably stick to and be like oh
okay like I get it right like an
opportunity to make an All-Star team
here there maybe not
um obviously Drew's a very elite
Defender I I'm not the defender that he
is but offensively like I've been able
to do some things that you know he's not
as good as I feel like I am at and we
actually share an agent so this is
nothing that would be news to anybody
I'm not taking shots to anybody but that
would be more so in the realm of you
know attack capacity all those other
things that I put myself in and
understand that you put me next to a
Giannis or a Luca or whatever like we
probably have a chance to win uh games
at a high level and you know I think
Brooklyn understands uh that really
realistic vision and like I said they
got all the picks to be able to do stuff
like that
so do those opinions that you disagree
with right has that ever shaken how you
view yourself
um
the only reason it hasn't is just
because the noise has been loud from a
very young age so I think that
I used to be more angry about it
um and as I've gotten older like I've
got a lot more calm with it
um so the ferocity of
or or the feeling of taking his
disrespect
um is a it's a lot more chill than it
used to be
when did you stop being angry with it
uh
uh when I stopped really caring about it
to a degree you know I mean like I you
you still do it's impossible for people
to say like you know certain things
about you and you're not to feel it but
I think
um you have to be like
okay with your accomplishments and okay
with your career and where it's gone be
happy with it all those other things and
and to be honest I'm like very proud of
my career considering the odds and
everything and where I've come from and
then also where I think I could still go
in the next you know or back nine of of
this thing and
as you have that internal security with
like what you've been able to accomplish
like you know
screwing up some parlays and really like
the biggest thing that you're worried
about yeah you're not concerned about
that no I love that you're saying this
because there's obviously been a lot of
discussion about Ring culture and just
the way that we value certain NBA
players accomplishments and I always say
that NBA players have their idea of what
success is in their career and if they
reach those things they feel like it is
success but a lot of the ways NBA
players define success is not how fans
or mass media define success I think
that you have to have a very specific
sense of security and self to be okay
with what just your definition is so
where do you fall on that subject and
how there is this major discrepancy and
what players think success is and what
everyone else thinks success is
um if I was speaking to a player right
now
um I love what you just kind of uh said
and lied to me because it really is
about you and what what you define
success
um I was actually just talking to one of
my younger teammates Deron Sharp
if you're not top five and I mean like
all time
two years three years after you're done
they're gonna forget about you bro like
let's be real about who we're still
talking about if you didn't change
culture like AI or Steph Curry with the
threes or you're not literally Kobe Mike
Braun
where do we talk about Penny Hardaway
yeah I'm saying do we talk about tmac do
we talk about Brandon Roy for real other
than injuries like and these are
monsters like we're talking about these
are doing some of the greats they're
great you know I'm saying like if Shaq
wasn't on TNT every night we may not be
talking about him as much and he's the
most dominant player in history so like
you're gonna have to Define cess for you
and I understand the ring chasing for
those guys because one more ring for
Braun can be the difference between him
being the goat or not or I caught Mike
or I caught this guy or I didn't
for
we people talk about Dame all the time
right for him
he's not going to be to go regardless
you know I'm saying like it's not going
to be that so if he's cool with his
career and he knows that he made the
right decision staying in Portland more
power to him I have no problem with him
and I'm not going to say he's the worst
player for it you know I'm saying like
he's
probably the second best three-point
shooting point guard in the history of
the game you know what I mean and and a
monster right like
so I that's that's really the way I view
it like I I fully understand the method
of ring chasing if you're right on that
cusp of like oh I could overtake hope or
I could overtake MJ or something like
that but like if you're
you know
top 20 and down which is basically
everybody else yeah bro it's about you
you know I'm saying and if you
respecting the game
then I have no problem with it I'm
saying like I have no problem with it
but do you think that's a critique of
the way we talk about basketball
or like a critique of player's mindset
about basketball does that make sense
uh man I think again right and this goes
back to kind of being the entertainment
industry right like
we all have to work in concert with each
other you know you guys are going to
have story lines that you talk about
um some that are sensationalized because
how you do your job right like part of
what made Mike and and hitting drove his
narrative and drove some of the star
power that league is the 6-0 like when
we have 100 million dollar contracts if
Mike don't do what he does like we
wouldn't and we're gonna have to we'd
have to attach
something to his narrative you know what
I mean like the mama mentality the
Kobe's like it's it's some of that stuff
is going to happen and we do play to win
like if you're really a true competitor
and I'm saying the guy that respects the
game you're going to play the game to
win
um so
I can't say that
it's it's on either party because like I
said it works together and I understand
that this machine
is always going to need a narrative
right it's always going to like I'll use
the Cavs and warriors remember like At
first Steph Curry was you know the the
hero the day reverse Goliath with LeBron
and then once he got KD and everybody
needs you know marvel teamed up then
LeBron became the sympathetic figure and
everybody was like oh it's not fair like
bra doesn't have any stars like that and
you know you have to kind of have those
moments to appeal to the masses so they
can feel involved and you can strike
emotional cords that resonate with them
with what you went
talking to a younger teammate about I
think you said was sharp yeah there has
to be
this peace that you have to have with
yourself and the career to say listen
I know what I am and what I'm not yeah I
know how people are going to talk about
me and how they're not I know what a win
would mean and what it wouldn't yeah
and I'm okay with being that player yeah
and I don't think it's easy for a lot of
players to get to that point
yeah I don't think so either
um in that respect I would say that I've
been blessed right to be able to do some
things that a lot of people haven't you
know 30 point games 40 points like you
know however many assists whatever and
so I there are things I can point to and
say like hey advance that say I'm the
best in the league at this I'm the best
at that and so these things that make me
Elite
whether you know mass media knows it or
not I know it you know I'm saying and
that is something that I can I can hold
on to and continue to show proof but
also have that peace if I was a player
that never got a chance to play
that's a that's a tougher conversation
because now I've never gotten a chance
to
show success or even to go out there and
fail I've just kind of been in the gray
area somewhere so I think it would be
harder if if that was the case
you know someone once said to me we were
talking about something else and they
said it's always important that you do
this [__] out of love and never for it
yeah and I think that for some NBA
players they play basketball
for the love yeah and I think that when
that's the thing that you're striving
for it's hard to have that sense of self
that you're referring to because success
to them is what do people think about me
and my career there you go where success
for you is what do I think about me and
my career exactly and did I do the
things that I'm saying I wanted to do
like you know I do want to experience
winning the championship and I think
that fire like his burn even brighter
after going to the Western Conference
finals and kind of experiencing that
atmosphere I wanted to be able to take
care of my family I've been able to do
that you know I'm saying that I wanted
to know internally that I was one of the
best to do it you know I'm saying and
and when I say best to do it I'm not
talking top five all the time but I'm
talking about like there's been billions
of people on this planet and I could
argue that I'm in the top 250 or so to
ever walk the Faces by definition
yeah like how many people have ever
averaged 20 points in a season or done
this or done that it's like I I could
argue I'm you know spitballing top 250
out of the billions of people that ever
walk the earth so it's like it's elite
yeah no I like that perspective you know
when you're talking about you know the
feeling of being wanted or unwanted you
mentioned Detroit yeah when I was
looking stuff up I saw a quote from
Andre Drummond
um where he said that every time you
play Detroit it felt like you had a
personal Vendetta against them I did I
was gonna say so did you oh 100 yeah 100
you can ask Stanley Johnson
um when I knew I was I wasn't going to
be there after my second year I said I'm
gonna come back and have a game winner
get shot I told him flat out I was I
mean shoot I was like 22 at the time I
was pissed like I was
you know hurt mad sad like
like I thought I knew I was good enough
I didn't just think I was gonna I knew I
was gonna know because I would be
killing in practice and like went on my
one-on-one drills and all that other
stuff and so you know I didn't know the
business of basketball and then how
could I know by my family never been to
the NBA and nobody in my circle had
really ever been to NBA I didn't I was
ignorant to it you know what I mean so
um I just thought hey I'm doing my job
in practice I'm showing up early I've
never been late I've never you know and
and then you know me I don't have like
many vices off the court or anything
like that I'm just hoping I'm like bro
I'm better than these dudes like what's
going on so there was a lot of
anger that I held towards a situation
and um
when I said I had released that several
years back it's because I had
back-to-back game winners against them
so after that I'm not Curative yeah I
was like all right [__] it I'll leave it
alone now okay do you have any personal
vendettas against any team now
um no not now
um
the the whole thing I mean the only team
that it could possibly be would be
Dallas right but
understanding business of basketball and
obviously with it being a superstar that
asked for a trade-in and understanding
my value in
where I am in the hierarchy and all that
other stuff you know how this thing goes
but it wasn't a situation where they
like kicked me out the door said mean
things they said look we love Spence but
we thought this was best for our team
well
I shake your hand and
you know agree to disagree so you don't
think it was best for the team no I'm
just saying in general like in general
yeah yeah okay so I'm actually surprised
you said that because I think that if
most people heard me ask that question
they think that you'd say I have a
personal Vendetta against the Wizards
Wizards so let's dive into the Wizards
yeah no we could definitely do that we'd
definitely do that what happened with
Washington why do you feel it did not
work out for you to be there
um
I don't think this is just a me thing so
I think um
if you look at the way that year started
coming together right they had a lot of
Trades a lot of roster turnover
um
a new head coach
trying to figure out an identity right
going in several different directions
right we had rui coming back from what
he was struggling with
um Denny was supposed to be like the you
know second coming of Luca you know you
got Brad who's obviously the max guy you
got the Lakers guys coming over who want
to establish themselves independently of
LeBron
um people playing for deals and like all
that stuff and and it was a situation
where you know
I was just saying like what are we doing
you know like
you remember I just I'm coming off
injury and I decided to do
a rather large one right so
technically speaking I didn't even need
to play nor was I gonna need to play for
a deal in order to need money or any of
that stuff right so it was like
can we just lay out like what the actual
plan is because like you know I thought
I was coming into a situation where I
was going to play number two to Brad and
Brad was going to you know do his 30
point thing and then we were gonna try
to piece this whole thing together to
try to build towards winning right like
that's what I was told and that's what I
plan on doing so but then like when the
narrative started to get spun that like
you know they were saying I wanted to
run the team or whatever else it was
like bro like I didn't even sign here to
do that so you're saying there's no
truth to that that you no okay no my and
and you know my guy who actually got
traded with me dollars for times like
he'll second all this stuff if you ever
want to interview him but it was that
was my hosting component was just what
are we doing you know if you can give me
Clarity I'll do it and I think the funny
part about it is
even when I said that back then and
everybody tried to spin it however they
tried to spin it and say what they said
about me the last year and a half have
shown that when I got traded to Dallas
first they were saying like hey six man
we want you to kind of be in that Gunner
sixth manual cool okay now that you're
starting to salute we need you to do a
little bit more catching and shooting
fine okay we need you to try and get
Christian with the ball a little bit
cool okay now you're back with Brooklyn
we need you to try to you know I'm
saying bring the team together and also
look to pass a little bit more cool like
if you can give me what I need to do
fine but if we're like
ah we got eight things we're trying to
do well I'm sitting here like bro what
are we doing you know and we're losing
on top of it
you you tell me because do you want me
to just sit down since like I'm coming
off ACL and you guys do whatever you're
doing or like you let me know so just
for clarification you're saying that
when you were saying what are we doing
and trying to figure it out you were
vocalizing that to the play like you
were trying to understand you were
actually asking this to them yeah I'll
ask the question like and and not even
to the players like I'll ask questions
to the coaches like and and not in a
disrespectful manner or saying like yeah
we can't run this game we can't I'm not
a dude that dictates schemes or anything
like that I'm just saying like give me
my clear concise directions so I can try
to do whatever you need me to do to the
best of my ability and and that was the
and like I said the funniest part about
how I got kind of bashed out the door
was the last year and a half has shown
you that I wasn't lying because when in
Dallas when they told me to like focus
on cashing shooting in certain aspects
of the game
well I was at one point in time like
leading the league in corner three
catching shoot yeah I'm saying at the
beginning of this year so it's like look
whatever you give me and that's
something I actually pride myself on as
a basketball player is having the
ability to do all these things oh you
need me to catch you for Luca I'll be
one of the best cats to shoot
three-point Shooters in the league oh
you need me to you know figure out how
to play make for a team that's kind of
got thrown again at the trade deadline
I'll be a top five assist type guy in
the league oh you need me to ISO in a
six-man role
um if you know Luke or JB and cooking at
night
I'll be the top ISO guy in the league
like you let me know
you know I'm saying it may take me seven
eight games to get a handle on it but
yeah but I'll get there but I will get
there you tell me I got you so for you
it was just more like you didn't feel
like there was clear direction or
Communication in terms of what your role
was going to be within the confines of
the system in Washington yeah and and
just how we were going to as a unit move
forward you know what I mean like
if we got a true max guy which we we do
or did right sorry um and Brad like why
are we not flowing through him you know
I'm saying like that's how I was raised
in illegal if we got a Max guy the same
way like in Dallas and Bradley can go
around yeah
so that's why that's why I said it was
it was so weird when the narrative got
spawned like I tried to go in there and
take over because like remember I signed
there for a reason I signed there to
play second field of brat I didn't sign
there to take over the team that didn't
make any sense like he was there had
been there for nine years or something
at the time or eight years of time I
don't know something like that like
there was no piece of like oh I'm coming
to take over DC like it was illogical
but
it got thrown out there media ran with
it and
that was then the label like you know
and you know if that was the case I
would have went to the Dallas and try to
take Lucas spot yeah yeah well there
were there were times after where it
felt unclear what happened because it
felt like there was a time after you
played them it was like you kind of had
a job in the locker room after the game
and then it was like who's kind of had a
job and so we're like what's going on
dispenser and Kyle kuzma not get along
like what's the what's the situation and
so I think that's how it yeah no I mean
as far as like me and Cruz like like no
we don't really speak but we weren't
like friends prior to DC or anything
like that like my friends you actually
know is Joe Harris Charis Jared I was
like a lot of the dudes I grew up with
in the league like those Brooklyn guys
that are really my guys
um and I have cool relationships uh with
you know a lot of different people now
especially some of those Dallas guys
Dwight Powell Maxi Josh Green those type
guys
um and and now doe obviously too who
came over with me but the the premise of
what I was saying at the time was we
have an MVP in Dallas right potential
MVP which are you calling me reading the
quote so the people listen oh yeah so
this is the quote
the quote was they're not playing for
nothing for real it's a showcase they're
over there trying to get paid not trying
to play winning basketball and that
caused a bit of a stir yeah yeah which
I stand by like at the end of the day
like if I here's the thing you know me
I'm a very honest dude if I'm gonna say
something especially in the media and
I've thought about my words I'm gonna
stand on what I said like I'm not a guy
that's gonna be like oops oh no I didn't
mean that remember it goes back to my
time there if there's a lack of clarity
on what we should be doing
well then naturally right a human being
is going to say well I'm gonna carve out
my little piece of this so I can get
mine like that's
how it happens like if there's no no
clear like that we're doing XYZ
well then yeah like think about it like
let's say let's say in Dallas we
just go to the West Conference Finals uh
Team right you knew Luke was going to
come out do his thing JB was going to
come out and do his thing and if one of
them were kind of off
well then I was gonna come out and try
to I'm saying do my thing and if both of
them were on well that's probably a
catch a shoe guy everybody else rebound
defend you know I'm saying whatever your
role maybe energy whatever your role was
you did it but let's say like we didn't
have Direction
well then maybe Maxie decides he wants
to shoot 15 times that day maybe Dwight
Howard decides he wants to bring the
ball up
maybe you know like it would it would
just be random you know what I'm saying
and when you are in a situation like
that where people start doing random
things and so that's what you've seen
over the course of
the last year and a half or so with them
so and and then the problem with where
we were at in Dallas at the time was if
we have an MVP and we're trying to get
back to the conference where we were
because that was relatively early in the
season
um
we can't lose to a team that's not in
that same level of like aspirations
they're not trying to do the same things
they don't have the same goals you know
I mean like if you go to Milwaukee and
lose because Giannis has 50.
are we really that upset about it like
no probably not like you know he had a
night in MVP had a night another
championship caliber team had a night
but like we
needed to start winning the games
that we needed to win like we had a game
early in the season where we were up
like 20 in the fourth to OKC and lost
you know there were there were a lot of
kind of moments and that's what that
quote was behind was where the Dallas
team was at the time where we needed to
focus and also understanding how it kind
of functions in DC it was less so a like
specific shot because I don't really had
no beef with nobody in the NBA like like
I said you know me I go home and I'll be
chilling I don't really even see these
dudes in the summer for real like
like yeah I get up at six at five a.m
and train and twice a day and all that
stuff and then if I decide to play
pickup I go see him but other than that
I'm
back with my son before these dudes are
waking up you're like it's not a beef
thing and yeah to be clear I mean
Bradley's great he's good on the show I
think he's a great player I think he is
the nicest human who's is my friend I
think kooza is great as well so I
understand that you're like this is
really just like a basketball thing that
you're speaking to but did it bother you
that that narrative was out there about
you in terms of
I just feel like it was
The Narrative was sort of that you were
why it didn't work did that bother you
of course yeah of course because I knew
I knew it wasn't true
um
but again
this entertainment industry you need
scapegoats sometimes you need to have
places that you put blame and it's a
easy target you could uh talk about my
outspoken nature you could talk about
brutal honesty you could talk about the
fact I was coming off injury you could
talk about you could you can always pick
things about people the same way you
could pick positive things so they pick
some things that you know you could take
negative in
you live with it well now you've cleared
it up look at that there we go the
importance of speaking hey on yourself
exactly all right shifting gears a
little bit
describe your relationship with MBA
referees in one word
tumultuous
why is it tumultuous
um
I mean obviously everybody knows about
what happened early in the season so I'm
not really talking about that I think um
you know I want to win and so if there's
a a play that I feel like
puts me at a disadvantage of winning the
game that is you know factually
incorrect
then I have a reaction to it
um overall right it's a it's a
cumulative thing too so you can't get
caught up with everything in a vacuum
and understand that if it continues to
build and it could harm you even more
long term and so it's it's a balancing
act because if you're quiet sometimes
it gets worse too because they're like
ah we're just gonna keep coming at them
and so it really is kind of this fine
line of like hey yo that wasn't correct
I need you to watch out for this I gotta
talk to you I'm saying I'm gonna have a
reaction but also I can't be you know
over the top to where it's deemed
disrespectful or counter uh productive
to the group as a whole so
so you're balancing okay when do I talk
to them when do I not yeah do you ever
feel like you're talking to them too
much do you feel like you're talking to
them when it feels right and maybe it's
just it feels right A lot of the time
um I think that's the the hard part
about uh being emotional right like I
put my heart and soul into this and so
there's a certain emotion
um that's tied into it and
the fans wouldn't like it if I didn't
have emotion tie to this and I didn't
care about winning
um I I do know that there are times that
I do it too much
um and like I said it's a it's a it's a
balancing act
um and then it's also highlighted with
having a little bit younger team and
needing to kind of or younger in terms
of Team being put together and you need
to kind of show a little bit more
Resolve and Leadership versus you know
being in possibly some other different
situations where it's like hey like I
can go at them three or four times but
you know it's it's going to be perceived
differently okay so obviously
I was going to find I'm not asking you
to criticize or anything like that but
what do you want to see from refs
oh
um
I would say personally first and
foremost I think the the main thing is
like
I hope that they know that the players
understand their job Ain't Easy
you know I think um
a lot of times reactions happen
while we're also emotional too right
whether it be a missed call or be a loss
game or attack or rejection or something
you know we lose money Etc and then yeah
rightfully so we're upset with you right
um
I think they need to also understand
that like we do know that they got the
heart one of the hardest jobs in the
world right bang bang plays removing at
high speeds like you're not gonna get
everything right so players are
cognizant of that and when we have those
reactions like we're we're speaking to
the stripes we're not speaking to the
person so I think sometimes uh if it
does come off disrespectful and they
have an emotional reaction back then it
just it builds and now you got two you
know
prideful people you know that are at the
top of their crafts going at each other
and then nobody wants to yield so I
would say that that Dynamic is probably
one where
that would be my only correction for
them just because
inherently their job is to be not
emotional I know as hard as a human
being but that is part of their job
description you know I'm saying so even
if we come at you with some emotion
your job description is still no emotion
and that's hard you know I'm saying it's
not easy and it's an unenviable position
but it is I'm saying your job like
you're saying that you're always saying
like
the burden of being even killed is not
on me it's on you technically speaking
Yeah like that's part of yeah I'm saying
because you're you're the one that's
impartial and unbiased and all that
stuff I'm biased I'm biased to the Nets
I'm biased dispenser every single night
every single night I am biased to the
Nets I'm by suspension so if Mikhail
gets fouled I'm on it if Nick you know
I'm saying shouldn't have got a travel
car I'm on it right and yes
I need to approach you with respect to
build Good Will and good faith over the
course of this game over the course of
the season over the course of long term
at the same time if I have an emotional
reaction
you still by definition can't be
emotional because if the Nets are
playing the Cavs you can't have a motion
one way or the other
um but I just I just you know my message
to them would just be like I want them
to know that players in general and I'm
not just speaking for myself we
understand a job and he's like yeah we
completely understand that especially
when you have these style conversations
in a removed place you know I'm saying
where it's not immediately post game we
lost and they're like what do you think
well they shot 15 on Fritos what you
think I think yeah I'm saying but
removed I'm like nah like I understand
your job's hard like I'm not sitting
here like saying it's easier that y'all
are the worst in the world we understand
y'all at the top of your craft the same
way I'm in the top of mind no
I'm also I'm not asking you to dive into
what happened with you earlier in the
season but did you ever get a chance to
speak to that ref one-on-one no okay not
any desire to not really okay not really
but I assume you've seen him since nope
okay so that'll be interesting yeah yeah
okay got it I just wanted to check and
see if anything was able to uh be
resolved
um I was watching the Nets game against
the Thunder when you didn't like the
lack of a call from a ref and you very
audibly yelled yeah
I was thinking you know I've never seen
Spencer angry or mad before yeah what's
the most angry you've ever been on the
basketball court oh that might have been
one of them okay besides that one
uh [__]
I I don't know but I gotta I got a story
for how that kind of went down and why I
did so
for me personally some of the
very small outbursts whatever it's kind
of like
blowing off some steam like you got a
teapot or whatever you let off some
steam right
um
so I I had a couple people come to me
like look I just need you to be quiet
the entire game
a couple people meaning Nets teammates
uh like a teammate my mom like just some
people it was like and I was like all
right whatever we on a little winning
streak I'll be quiet during the OKC game
so things are starting to stack up and
I'm like all right I already know like
they've been hacking I'm like bro like
y'all really playing with me right now
they test me right now so
um we had like a lead and it's kind of
you know going south and then found a
couple times whatever and I'm still kind
of keeping it chill so
um and so they kind of take the
lead take control of the game and um so
now obviously like I gotta kind of get a
little more aggressed start attacking
and that specific player right there was
so blatantly a foul like it was it
wasn't even remotely close you know what
I'm saying and I've been kind of getting
like smug looks and stuff from the rest
because the rest of it even actually
heard one of our conversations was like
wow so no complain you know I'm saying
before for the game so he's talking and
stuff and I'm thinking like all right
whatever like oh this is a big deal huh
Spencer being quiet okay since they're
not gonna talk to us or whatever oh did
pigs fly yeah you know what I'm saying
something all right whatever bro so all
right you in a good mood cool let me
give me a couple calls um
so that was so obviously a foul and with
everything that had gone on the fact
that we had lost the lead the game was
kind of now getting out of hand and
because it was it felt like they were
playing in my face because of like the
pregame joke and like all the other
stuff and blah blah so that's why I was
just I I was I had it with like the the
entire situation and I was like listen
I'd rather just do me and get a tech
here or there you know I'm saying it's
not like it's not like I got 18 of them
and I'm leaving just do me get attacked
no I'm saying I'd rather I'd rather go
back to you know I'm saying the the
other stuff and yeah and
being more level-headed and also at
least feeling like I'm defending myself
to a degree because I've never been
somebody that was just like
attorney at the cheek like that wasn't
that wasn't the way I was raised my dad
was raised me to be like yo like don't
start nothing but if they start
something you finish it and so that's
the way I take things like
most children in the world but if you
start it like oh we can go wherever you
want to go with it like that's how I
live life yeah and so it's very hard to
like turn that off when for 29 years
I've lived life in that manner like oh
where where are we going with this I
will go wherever and further
period further period like that's I mean
[__] that's that's how my career has
been able to survive you know I'm saying
we talk about work we talk about it's
almost like your reflex that's the
reflex yeah and so it very rarely
actually takes me out of the game
because it's a reflex and it's done it's
part of who I've been the entirety of my
life I get though that the perception is
that like I go somewhere off of a whole
nother planet and I'm disruptive to the
team and like I said when you're with a
more
veteran team it doesn't really affect
the other guys like you know I'm doing
that okay Dwight power and Maxi probably
ain't tripping yeah I'm saying but if
now I'm the more core leader of this
versus a you know peripheral leader and
we are in a new situation okay well now
I have to
tone that down and kind of restructure
my reactions but I'm doing that for the
good of the group not just being quiet
and getting slapped in the face so I can
put what I want to decide for the good
of the unit and I will do that at any
point in time because the unit is what
matters in winning is what matters but
if I'm just sitting here being quiet and
y'all just playing with me
hey that ain't gonna work too well so
right now the word are using to describe
relationship with the refs is tumultuous
what word would you like it to be what
word are we looking to end on amicable
amicable cordial yeah cordial okay
that's good that's that's going to be
our goal that's the goal for 2024. yeah
New Year New Meme
um you spoke to Forbes about coaching
and you had a great quote that I wanted
to recite to you you said to me coaching
at this level it's 80 psychologist 10
temperament 10 X's and O's it's mostly
about managing the egos yeah when has
that stance and opinion been the most
clear to you
two
that's probably
um seeing the transition that we went
from you know young upstarts that
kind of had their quirks to then
Champion expectations with you know I'm
saying the guys and everything it's just
you know
even
there's only been what 5 000 or so NBA
players in history uh like we said
there's been billions and billions of
people on the planet
we're all Elite we're all going to think
we're the best we're all gonna have all
this stuff but to try to get you know a
nine-man rotation to bind to a royal
function is one when they may have been
you know they say Pat bad was like a 35
point-of-game score in high school I'm
saying now like we leave them open you
know I'm saying sometimes because it's
like oh we want him shooting more than
we want Zach Levine shooting is that an
indictment on him or his talent not
really it's just that's how we're gonna
play and so you got to get all these
Eagles in check for them to work
together and then it's like for example
credit to him he'll still make the extra
pass to Zach so Zach can still get his
shot you know I'm saying stuff like that
and and that's really what the NBA is
about
um because at the end of the day you
know roster construction is going to
have a much bigger indicator on whether
you're going to win a championship then
exynos like X and O still you you know
maybe
four to six points you know I'm saying
eight points maybe but like
if I got the 2017 or 18 Warriors
Hey listen bro you're like we good we
winning a lot of we're winning a lot of
games like we're winning a lot of games
no no shots Steve Kerr and he just won a
title with a lesser team I'm just saying
in no specific situations because I know
everything is clickbaity and hot taking
and all that other stuff like I'm not
talking about bad about nobody yeah
you're just saying there was a crazy
good yeah that was a that was a roster
that was an insane roster that was going
to win if you were their coach yeah
excuse me
okay
so you use the Nets as an example
if this was you know you put on your
coaching cap for a day
how would you have managed those egos on
the Nets
the reason why I brought
um the Nets was because I was a part of
it and I watched some of it but I also
watched a lot of it from afar because
when I got hurt I did go to La and you
know participated in my whole training
schedule and then I went to DC so
to say what I would do differently
I I can't really answer that because I
wasn't in the day-to-day and see all the
little pieces I was like there from like
day one to day like five but day five
today 100 I missed it well what general
role do you think ego plays in the NBA
as a whole no it's huge
it's huge I would say for the most part
it's everything right because
you need your stars to
have insanely huge Egos and confidence
and all other stuff because they got to
be able to take the last shot and they
got to be able to do these things at a
high level every single night a certain
amount of mental toughness is just you
know 82 games a lot yeah you know and
then you have to have guys
4 through 15.
put their egos completely to the side
yeah I'm saying and maybe not play
tonight or maybe player all the other
stuff and still cheer on the bench and
still be you know bring positive energy
and Good Vibes so it's this like crazy
dual Dynamic where like one through
three have to believe in themselves to
an insane degree and four through
fifteen have to say hey they have to
acquiesce to one through three and put
their pride on the side
but then if somebody in the one through
three gets hurt somebody gonna have to
step up and then flip the switch and
become one of those it's the the
psychological Battle of the NBA is is
why a lot of people don't make it like
there's people overseas that I know are
talented enough to play in the league
like there's probably
you know another 100 200 guys that
probably could be in the NBA but but it
was that mental element yeah they're
probably they're just not cut for it for
real but if you put them on a basketball
floor they could they play with us for
sure yeah who's the most egoless
NBA star
oh star uh I don't know I thought you're
gonna say Just Player Anthony Gill by
far Wizard's teammate he is the most
quality human being that I've ever met
in the National Basketball Association
Bar None it's Anthony okay
I'll say
you've seen a lot you've been around a
lot of teams you've played with stars
are you saying because this is my thing
with ego I get it's hard to manage I
understand there's this major
psychological element in the NBA but you
could argue that that ego is one of the
things you need to be one of those you
have to stars or Superstars or whatever
like it's necessary too the stardom yeah
in some way and he goes it bad right
like I don't think ego has to be some
negative thing it's like it's either a
very strong belief in yourself or it's
the belief that no one is better than
you at this thing or this belief that
just your pride is not going to be heard
and if it is it's not going to be
because of something that you did to me
on this basketball court you know I
think that you actually need that to be
able to propel to that spot in general
really one thousand percent yeah
um just I mean my my career is a
testament to that right if I was a more
mentally fragile human being or I didn't
have in an ego that
although realistic had its insane belief
I wouldn't be here you know I'm saying I
wouldn't be able to like like sincerely
when I step on the floor I don't believe
that anybody can guard me and I've said
that when I was
you know back in 2017 and got laughed at
and all that stuff but like why why
would I come into this game thinking
that you could stop me yeah I'm saying
like you're gonna have to show me that
you can and and not just show me once
like consistently over and over and over
now
I get the Dynamics of the business and
so if I have you know Luca next to me I
understand he's shooting 20 times I'm
shooting 10. it is what it is it's the
business and that's how our team's going
to run and that's what's best for our
team but don't think in those 10
attempts that like
I'm thinking you're gonna stop this like
nah yeah
um absolutely and that's all you have to
be yeah well okay speaking of stars
speaking of Luca what do spectators not
understand about Lucas game that someone
who has his teammate now understands
about his game
and just how special he is
athletically speaking he's a lot quicker
than than people think they think
because he the way his body looks and
stuff that he has zero athleticism
that's not the case he's actually very
strong he's very quick he's not
necessarily fast though
um
I think
the other thing too about the the timing
and pace of his game is extremely tricky
like
anybody that plays at one speed all the
time you start to pick up a Cadence it's
almost like a song right and if you can
catch the like the beat you can start to
time it right there's a lot of things
that he does it's just it's just off
it's like Southpaw right it's just off
like
typical MBA timing like some of his
passes that he throws are just like
super late you know and that's hard for
you to get used to unless you see it
every single day so as a teammate you
start to pick up on like oh this is what
he's doing but when you see him twice a
year you're like what the hell did he
just do like how'd he do this yeah I
mean that works his Advantage exactly
um and I think that along with his
obviously phenomenal basketball accused
what makes him so special and like what
is Luca's personality is he funny is he
serious is he quiet is he like I don't
what I mean like what's he act like I
mean he's just a cool dude he's fairly
chill but he's got he got his jokes he's
funny he's around the guys and stuff
he's not like you know off to the side
or like some weird emo guy or something
like that I didn't think he was either
sure
he plays little jokes and stuff he's
just a just a good guy like he's a good
dude okay perfect last uh kind of
section for you obviously Spencer you
are someone I've known for a long time I
know you well on this show I like to
give people the opportunity to talk
about things that are special to them
and mean something to them
um so I want to give you a chance to
talk about how special your grandma was
to you
um and just what she meant to your
overall life
oh man uh
he got me with that one
uh
I think
my grandma was probably the place that I
felt the most authentic and and truest
love in my life
and
that's why that's a relationship that
I mean quite honestly I don't really
talk about much
um
she uh
you know it's expectations that that
come with other relationships and
and I mean that like my dad and you know
Mom and stuff and and they love me to
death they'd take a bullet for me but
you know whether it be
wanting me to score or wanted me to be
good at this or
stuff it with my grandmother it was just
about like
it's being me like I was I was enough
you know what I'm saying and
I think that's uh
that that's that is like a
sorry you really got me but that's it's
it's such a unique thing to feel and
I I think that everybody at some point
in time in their life I hope that they
have a relationship just like that
where
especially in your formative years as a
kid you're just
your smile you can tell it's your smile
changes their day and their smile
changes your day and that you two just
sitting with each other regardless of
whatever it is it was it was just enough
for that day
so that was my girl man yeah
what do you feel like
it's about you
she loved her most
I think um
she's probably
one of the only people that's
experienced like uh
the the warmth in my heart that I
that I probably tuck away more than I
should
um
you you got really real in this
conversation to end it no no no it's
cool uh because
yeah I mean I I think um
you know it'd be easy to say like
intelligence or like our jokes and stuff
like that because we used to joke about
all type of [__] but
I think
um
especially as a kid like that's that's
what I remember most
like
the warmth Embrace I think we knew what
each other was thinking a lot of times
um like when I'd sit with her you know
I'm saying before she passed like we
just kind of
could just sit there together you know
what I'm saying and
and uh
yeah no I mean not to get into any like
real specific stories because the the
two the two things that actually uh
can make me cry my son and my grandma so
like if I start getting the stories it
might get a little get a little awkward
on the show so that's you can feel
whatever you want to feel on the show no
I appreciate you sharing that uh
yesterday actually my grandma got out of
the hospital she's fine she's healthy
um but I actually thought about
conversations that we had had about
Grandma when she was in there because
you just think to yourself all the time
like
your grandparents are these people that
love you so much and it is so important
to just call them yeah and talk to them
yeah and like when we have people in our
lives that like we literally only exist
because they were alive so they've
always been in our life
we don't know what it's like to not have
them there all the time
and we because of that we then take it
for granted that they're there all of
the time
um so just been watching I just hope
this is a reminder to call your parents
call your grandparents if you are
blessed enough to have all those people
um you're gonna make me want to cry plus
enough to have all those people on the
planet on that too yeah um
you know when she when she was sick
I never missed a day sitting with her
and I think that
you know when what happened happened
that was something that gave me peace so
as you said to people in kind of a
little call to action like
I I would have so much regret if that if
I didn't treat that situation like I did
even though it it wasn't fun to see her
the way that I'm saying she would be
sometimes like
knowing what those moments meant to her
and then obviously like the regret that
I don't feel
that was uh
that was huge so yeah for for the people
if you're going through something like
take that extra moment for sure and I
love that you're like you were able to
be peaceful because you know that she
met she knew what she meant to you and
you knew what you meant to her because
you all had those conversations I do
want to ask them just because I thought
it was beautiful that you said that how
did your relationship with your grandma
influence the way that you parent Elijah
uh
uh man I would say that
being with her and knowing what I love
so much about that relationship
I've tried to
have a standard for for excellence
that probably came from my parents but
less uh
expectation or qualification on it more
so just trying to be like yo like
you're you're enough you know like you
are
whatever you choose to be NASA
basketball whatever like I don't I'm not
pushing to play basketball none of that
stuff I hope he does let's be clear I
hope he does
um I think I think that's uh and then I
kiss him a lot
I think um
that's something that
prior
if you had if you had asked me if when I
was 21 like if I'd kiss my son at 10 I'd
probably be like nah but like that's
something that I do all the time I kiss
him all the time and I just try to
reiterate that he's enough and you know
that my love for him isn't predicated on
success or failure or anything like that
yeah
sharing that no problem I think it's
it's genuinely important I'm happy that
everyone got to at least know a piece of
how special she was um and what what she
meant to your life
um we always end these with a what if
question it's about basketball but what
if you could perfect one move on the
court what is it
just one just one
oh I'd be able to
shoot threes from half courted like a
knife like a like a 90 clip yeah you
gotta pick me up at half court buddy I'm
firing it yeah I mean that is the way
this thing is evolving yeah I mean
that's going to be able to happen then
at first I was gonna say Skyhook but
then I was like ah that kind of sucks
yeah like that's Layman yeah
you would just be checking them up oh
for sure half court just
70 clip yeah good answer no truly I
appreciate your time I appreciate your
openness your honesty your perspective
on all of the things both Bachelor
related and not I'm glad we got to
finally do this so thank you for
stopping by and coming on the show
nothing about me
[Music]
foreign